- [Voiceover] Let's now explore the first
law of thermodynamics.
And before even talking
about the first law of
thermodynamics, some
of you might be saying,
"Well, what are thermodynamics?"
And you could tell from
the roots of this word.
You have thermo, related to thermal,
it's dealing with temperature.
And the dynamics, the
properties of temperature,
how do they move, how
does temperature behave?
And that's pretty much
what thermodynamics is,
it's about, it's the study
of heat and temperature,
and how it relates to energy and work,
and how different forms of energy can be
transferred from one form to another.
And that's actually the heart of the
first law of thermodynamics
which we touched on
on the introduction to energy video.
And the first law of
thermodynamics tell us
that energy,
this is an important one,
I'm going to write it down,
energy cannot be created or destroyed.
Cannot be created,
or destroyed.
It can only be converted
from one form to another.
It can only
only be converted
only be converted,
I'm having trouble writing today.
Converted from one form,
from one form,
to another.
Or you could transfer it
but you're not going to,
you're not going to create or destroy it.
And the whole thing that
I, the rest of this video
I just want to really
have you internalize that,
and I want to look at a bunch
of examples and think about,
well, what is the energy
that we're observing,
or that we're seeing in a system?
And then thinking about
where is that energy
coming from, to appreciate
that it's not just
coming out of nowhere,
and that it's not just
disappearing, it's not
getting destroyed either.
And so let's start with
this example of a lightbulb.
And I encourage you to pause this video,
think about the forms of
energy that we can see here,
and then think about where
is that energy coming from,
and where is it going?
Well, the most obvious form
of energy that you see here,
and this, the whole point of a lightbulb,
is you see the radiant energy, you see the
you see the electromagnetic
waves, the light,
being emitted from it.
And that light, so this is radiant energy.
Radiant energy.
And that radiant energy,
is due to the heat in the
filament right over here,
as the electrons go through
it, it generates heat,
so you have thermal energy.
So you have thermal energy as well.
Thermal energy.
But where does this radiant and thermal
energy come from?
Again, first law of
thermodynamics it tells us,
it's not just being
created out of thin air,
it must be converted or being
transferred from some place.
Well, I just gave you a
hint, this thermal energy
is due to the electrons
moving through the filament.
They're moving through
the filament which has
some resistance, and that generates heat.
So the electrons are moving through this,
and as they move through that
resistor, they generate heat.
So you actually have the
kinetic energy of the electrons.
I'll just write KE for
short, kinetic energy
of the actual electrons.
Well, where is that
kinetic energy coming from?
Well that's coming from
the potential energy.
You know maybe this thing is plugged into,
is plugged into a socket of some kind.
So let me draw a little electric socket
right over here.
And the electric socket, I'll draw,
the electric socket if
this is the electric socket
in your home,
there is an electrostatic
potential between
these two terminals.
And so when you make a connection,
the electrons are able to move.
And we'll get into the
details of AC and DC current
in the future, but there's
an electrostatic potential,
from this point to this
point if we assume that's
the direction that the
electrons are going in.
And so that, it's that
potential energy we convert to
this kinetic energy of the electrons,
which is really in the form of a current,
and then that gets converted
into thermal energy
and radiant energy.
Now what happens after, let's
say you unplug the light,
the light goes dark, what
happened to all of that energy?
Is it still there?
Well yeah, that thermal
energy is going to continue
to dissipate through the system.
And this right over here
would be an open system,
it's going to,
the air inside the lightbulb,
you can't fully see
the lightbulb right here, but
it looks something like this.
That's going to heat up, but
then it's going to heat up
the glass surrounding the lightbulb,
and that's going to heat
up the surrounding air.
So the thermal energy is
going to be transferred,
and that radiant energy
is going to move outward.
And it could be used, it
could be converted into other
forms of energy, most
likely thermal energy,
it is also probably going
to heat up other things.
Well, what about a pool table?
When I hit a, if I hit a pool,
a billiard ball or a pool
ball right over here,
well, where is that energy going?
Well some of that energy
might be going to go hit
the next ball, which might
go to hit the next ball.
But as we all know, if
we've ever played pool,
at some point they're going to stop.
So what happened to all of that energy?
Well, while they were rolling,
there was some air resistance,
so they're bumping against
these, the air molecules,
and it's really friction due to air.
And that energy is essentially going to be
converted to heat.
And one trend that you're going to see
very frequently, is as systems progress,
a lot more of the energy
tends to turn into heat,
rather than doing useful work.
And so you're going to
have, as the billiard balls
move, there's the air,
and so that's going to be,
that's going to be converted,
some of that kinetic energy
is going to be turned into heat energy.
You're also going to have friction with
the actual felt on the table.
And that friction, you're
going to have molecules
rubbing up against each other,
that's also going to
be converted into heat.
And so that, because that
kinetic energy gets sapped off,
gets keeping sapped
away from the friction,
which is essentially
converting the kinetic energy
to heat energy, eventually you won't have
any more kinetic energy.
Now what about this weight lifter here?
He's using the chemical energy in his,
in the ATP in his muscles,
that converts into
kinetic energy that moves his muscles,
that moves this weight, but
once he's in this position,
what happened to all of that energy?
Well, a lot of that energy is
now being stored in potential.
it's the potential energy,
he's got this big weight,
he's got that big weight above his head,
and if he were to just let
go, that thing would fall,
I wouldn't recommend he do that,
but that thing would fall quite fast.
And so now it's all,
or a lot of it has been
stored up in potential energy.
But he would have also generated heat,
his muscles would have generated heat.
Even the act of moving it
through the air is going to be
some heat in the air,
some friction with it.
And so I want you to appreciate
that this energy is not
coming out of nowhere,
it is being converted
from one form or another,
or being transferred
from one part of the system to another.
Now we can look at these
examples over here.
Same thing with our
runner, what happens after,
you can buy the fact that
okay, his chemical energy is
allowing his muscles to
move, and that's turning in
his kinetic energy for his
entire body, his body is moving,
but at some point he stops,
where did all that energy go?
Well, some of it will be
heat in his body that's being
dissipated into the broader
system, into the air.
And also, when he was running,
there was this contact
with the ground, that's
going to make the molecules
of the ground vibrate a
little bit, some of it will be
transferred as sound, so the air particles
moving through the air, and
a lot of it will be heat.
And we're going to see that
over and over and over again.
The diver up here, you have
mostly potential energy.
Then it converts to
kinetic energy as he's,
as he gets almost in the water.
But what happens once
he falls into the water?
Well, then that energy's
going to be transferred,
as you're going to have these
waves of water move away.
And it will also increase
friction, so, well actually
he would have had
friction as he fell down,
so that would have generated some heat,
and there would have
been also some heat with
the friction with the water,
you normally don't think of
friction with the water,
but there is some friction
with the actual water, and there's also,
these waves, you have
higher kinetic energy
of the actual water
being transferred outward
from where he actually dropped in.
And I could keep going on and on.
You have the chemical potential
energy of the fuel here
being, you have combustion occurring,
and then that gets converted
into the thermal energy,
and the radiant energy of
what we associate with fire.
And that doesn't disappear,
it just keeps radiating outwards,
the radiant energy just
keeps radiating outward,
maybe it might heat up something.
And the thermal energy will
just keep radiating outward,
or I should say, the thermal
energy will just dissipate
outward, and heat up the things around it.
Same thing with our lightning example.
You start with the
electrostatic potential,
where the bottom of the
clouds were more negative,
and then the ground is positive as well,
and at some point, that
potential energy turns into
kinetic energy as the electrons
transfer through the air,
and then that gets converted
into, or a good bit is
going to be converted to
heat and radiant energy.
So the whole point of this
video is, no matter what
example you look at, if you
think about it carefully enough,
and I encourage you to do
this in your everyday life,
the energy isn't just coming out of,
you know, magically appearing,
it's just being converted
from one form to another.